digamos que he estado investigando
algunas acciones para potencialmente
invertir y me siento muy seguro en mi
habilidad para predecir que también le
va a ir a una compañía en relación con
las expectativas de la gente o con las
del mercado en particular me voy a
enfocar en las compañías a y b en el
caso digamos de la compañía vamos a
suponer que le irá mucho peor que de lo
que el mercado espera entonces me
encuentro tentado a disminuirlo en el
caso de la compañía de me parece que le
va a ir mucho mejor que las expectativas
del mercado entonces me encuentro
tentado a comprar oa irme largo pero hay
un segundo en este aspecto un poco
incómodo tengo confianza en mi habilidad
para elegir compañías que van a tener un
rendimiento mayor que el mercado o que
van a tener un mayor rendimiento
respecto a otras pero no tengo seguridad
en mi habilidad de cómo va a ir al
mercado en general déjenme dibujar una
gráfico del mercado digamos que este es
el precio del mercado y me he dado
cuenta que es tan bueno irse al azar
comprando con tratar de elegir suelos
del mercado o cimas del mercado entonces
mi temor es que sucede si compro en la
compañía de base
investigación concreta y luego el
mercado se va para abajo entonces la
compañía ve probablemente también se irá
para abajo tal vez disminuirá tanto como
el mercado pero aún así será se irá
abajo y perder perderé dinero qué tal si
reduzco en la compañía tal vez la
compañía no se elevará tal vez no se
elevará tanto como en el mercado pero
aún así perderé dinero en mi posición
corta verdad lo cual es una apuesta que
las acciones van a disminuir existe
algún arreglo que yo podría hacer alguna
combinación de comprar en la compañía ve
y vender o disminuir en la compañía
quién esencial le dará cobertura mucho
de este riesgo del mercado y cómo te
puedes imaginar si lo hay y no entrar en
todas las estadísticas de esto como la
estadística de eta y demás
no quiero realmente cubrir toda esta de
forma estadística pero la idea general
es bueno cómo hacer que si el mercado va
a rendir más
ok digamos ya supongo que va a rendir
menos en el mercado respecto a ver por
ejemplo puedo comprar una cantidad
similar de ve mientras disminuyó en la
compañía entonces en este caso hagamos
sólo una acción puedes puedes hacer
obviamente múltiples de esto verdad
puedes comprar una acción déjenme
ponerlo bien vamos a comprar una acción
de la compañía ve y puedes vender o
disminuir acciones de la compañía pues
tomar préstamos la acción y después que
tendrás que comprarlo en una fecha
futura verdad entonces si disminuyes dos
acciones de la compañía y el motivo por
el cual estoy diciendo que son dos
acciones en la es en vez de una acción
verdad es que nada digamos aquí valen
cinco dólares por acción y aquí en vez
vale diez dólares por acción
entonces vas a hacerlo aproximadamente
la misma cantidad verdad insisto no
quiero entrar a las estadísticas pero no
no nos vamos a preocupar por eso en
estos momentos entonces por simplicidad
lo que he hecho aquí es que hemos tomado
una posición larga en b digamos tomamos
una posición de 10 dólares
posición larga en vez de 10 dólares ok y
hemos tomado una posición corta una
posición corta en a también de 10
dólares verdad nuevamente a es de 5
dólares por acción entonces tomamos dos
acciones de a lo cual suma la misma
cantidad de dólares que la acción que
tome en b para pensamos en ello y tal
vez me lo guardé para el próximo vídeo
pero quiero que pienses en lo que sucede
si el mercado se mueve para abajo o para
arriba
cuál de las dos empresas me conviene
será la osera a la vez